Est-ce que tu savais que l’animal qu’on présente
comme l’un des plus dangereux de l’océan
est en réalité beaucoup moins terrifiant que tu
le crois ?
Je parle du requin.
La plupart des gens l’imaginent comme une
machine à tuer, assoiffée de sang.
Sauf que c’est complètement faux.
Les requins existent depuis 400 millions
d’années.
Ils ont traversé quatre extinctions massives et
étaient déjà là avant la disparition des
dinosaures,
il y a 66 millions d’années.
Mais le plus dingue, c’est qu’ils jouent aussi
un rôle essentiel dans l’équilibre des océans,
pour préserver les herbiers marins et les récifs
coralliens.
Aujourd’hui, il existe plus de 500 espèces de
requins,
mais seulement cinq sont présentées ici comme
réellement dangereuses pour l’homme :
le requin tigre, le requin bouledogue et le
grand requin-marteau,
le grand blanc et le requin océanique.
Et là, ça devient intéressant.
Selon l’International Shark Attack File,
environ 64 attaques sont rapportées chaque année
dans le monde, pour seulement quatre morts.
Mais attends.
Chaque année, 30 personnes mourraient à cause de
fourmis rouges
et 150 à cause de chutes de noix de coco.
Donc oui, selon ces chiffres, une noix de coco
serait plus dangereuse qu’un requin.
Mais le vrai prédateur de cette histoire, ce
n’est pas lui.
C’est nous.
Chaque année, les humains tuent environ 80
millions de requins
pour leurs ailerons utilisés en médecine
traditionnelle et dans des soupes.
Et finalement, le monstre qu’on craignait depuis
le début n’était peut-être pas celui qu’on
pensait.